[Música]
bienvenidos a ello soy de france24 este
episodio nos lleva a bolivia en promedio
cada tres días y cuatro horas muere una
mujer por crímenes relacionados con
violencia machista en ese país las
autoridades registran que desde el
primero de enero de 2021 ya hay
alrededor de 67 feminicidios confirmados
del otro lado están las sobrevivientes
que siguen siendo vulnerables
principalmente ante sus parejas o
exparejas y más ahora que la pandemia
cambio el ritmo de la vida y nos dejó en
casa sin opciones en vivencia de esa
lacerante realidad sufren las mujeres
pero también sus comunidades sus
familias y sus hijos y ello empujó a un
grupo de pequeños a realizar una
película casera que se estrenó a
mediados de julio para mostrar desde sus
ojos cómo se ve la violencia de género
son siete niños entre los 5 y los 15
años quienes formaron el grupo de los
trovadores y tos viven en el alto y
quisieron explorar el arte y el cine
para hablar de violencia machista veamos
el informe de meriva que no estás
mintiendo
la violencia machista que veía en las
casas de sus amigos llevó al niño george
ney paca de 12 años a hacer vídeos para
denunciarla y a formar un elenco de
niños llamado los trovadores y tos para
dirigir la película otro día más basta
de violencia basta de feminicidios
si hay maltrato en una familia va a ser
como una cadena cuando sus hijos crezcan
así que hemos tomado mucha importancia a
este primer proyecto que se ha ido
alargando mucho para convertirse en una
película por el tiempo de duración
y su compromiso con un tema tan delicado
no impide a youznhy y sus amigos
comportarse como niños sus padres están
orgullosos muy felices de tener un hijo
que está interesado por cambiar la
sociedad la violencia machista que el
joven director denuncia está muy
arraigada en bolivia en lo que va del
año 67 mujeres han sido asesinadas por
esa causa y 23.000 denunciaron
agresiones en la familia según cifras
oficiales las autoridades dicen que la
causa está en la forma en que son
criados muchos bolivianos
quien deja de ser el proveedor el que
trae los recursos económicos al hogar y
la mujer ingresa a este nivel entonces
se siente menos porque porque su
pensamiento machista patriarcal le ha
hecho pensar es
desde pequeñito lo han criado así por
eso el mensaje de estos niños haciendo
cine se valora tanto al punto que su
película ha sido estrenada en el alto y
en la paz creando conciencia sobre la
prevención de la violencia machista
desde una temprana edad
para conversar del tema está con
nosotros desde la paz bolivia la doctora
marines salazar gutiérrez page y en
investigación transdisciplinaria y
educación y especialista en sexualidad
doctora bienvenida a ella soy y quiero
comenzar de una vez preguntándole los
trovadores hitos de bolivia hablan de
una violencia que no nos es ajena por el
contrario está completamente normalizada
las mujeres somos víctimas inmediatas
pero los niños que están educando crecen
expuestos a esa violencia como rompemos
esos círculos de abuso
bueno es un gusto para mí poder
compartir con ustedes este análisis y
lamentablemente tenemos que abordar un
tema como este en bolivia hemos estado
haciendo análisis profundos sobre el
tema y nos hemos encontrado con que
existe una espiral de la violencia una
espiral que comienza por una violencia
simbólica
planteada por mandatos ideas mensajes
que se transmiten a través de las
generaciones dentro de las familias a
través de temas musicales de recitación
es de imágenes etcétera que perpetúan el
lugar de la mujer como un objeto de
reproducción de producción y de
exhibición y el lugar del varón como un
instrumento de consumo de control y de
ataque esta violencia simbólica aparece
en las familias a manera de discursos y
como bien decían en la entrevista
a manera de crianza machista pero al
mismo tiempo
aparece como violencia mediática porque
diferentes medios de comunicación
transmiten estos estereotipos de lo que
significa ser mujer y lo que significa
ser hombre es más en algunos medios no
en todos se explota el morbo en torno a
la violencia que sigue generando esta
espiral a partir de ello identificamos
ya que la violencia psicológica que
aparece en espacios más íntimos como
pueden ser la familia la escuela o la
pareja reproduce todos estos mandatos y
van perpetuando lo en acciones y ahí
aparecen las violencias sexuales las
violencias físicas y terminan en
violencias femicidas mira el ejemplo que
veíamos de otro día más es una expresión
infantil y francamente muy sincera de la
vulnerabilidad que usted nos describe y
que enfrentamos las mujeres y aquí por
eso le pido que nos aclare aunque
pareciera obvio porque cuando una mujer
sufre maltrato
solamente la mujer sufre en todos una
sociedad que permite abuso al final es
una sociedad arcade que subdesarrolladas
bueno justamente porque estamos hablando
de esta espiral que hace que no
solamente sea una mujer como individuo
de la sociedad la que esté recibiendo
todo este impacto de la violencia
simbólica mediática psicológica sexual
física sino todo el sistema del cual
forma parte en este sentido una mujer
que ha sido socavada ya en su estima por
todos estos mensajes
sociales pues con mucha facilidad va a
entrar a una relación de pareja donde
haya dependencia donde haya la idea de
que para desarrollarse necesita sostener
una relación por muy violenta que sea y
por supuesto sistémicamente también los
niños las niñas que están alrededor van
tomando aquellos mensajes en el caso de
los trovadores y tos para denunciarlos
para confrontarlos en bolivia también se
está trabajando mucho para que las niñas
y los niños se asuman a sí mismos como
sujetos de derechos pero no todos tienen
está está dicha y esta suerte muchos
solamente se constituyen en un eslabón
de esta cadena de violencia tenemos que
romper esto increíble que los derechos
humanos sean ahora también una cuestión
de privilegio usted es especialista en
temas de sexualidad y la violencia
machista se relaciona mucho con la forma
en que percibimos precisamente nuestra
sexualidad nos educa el porno nos
relacionamos desde la niñez en una forma
desigual entre hombres y mujeres y
aprendemos a comunicarnos pero aún
existe en la mente colectiva la idea de
que hay pertenencia de la mujer o que la
mujer es inferior y no una igual aunque
no seamos conscientes de ello si estamos
viendo las consecuencias
así es ese es otro campo que hay que
trabajar muchísimo estamos acá en
bolivia
insistiendo que en sexualidad sexo coito
y erotismo no son lo mismo porque
solamente si entendemos esto vamos a
poder generar una educación integral de
la sexualidad una que se dirija a la
vida misma y no solamente al hecho
reproductivo y no solamente a el hecho
genital
el que nos reconozcamos nuestro cuerpo
como nuestro territorio la autonomía de
nuestro cuerpo que nos conozcamos el
placer como un derecho hace que muchas
personas niñas niños adolescentes y
mujeres se pongan en el riesgo de caer
primero en las redes internas de
maltrato y luego en las redes externas
también de
violencia tú vienes manifestado por
ejemplo que el hecho de que no haya
educación integral de la sexualidad
aquella que nos permita acompañar la
sexualidad de infantes niñas niños
mujeres adolescentes jóvenes etcétera
más allá de la reproducción hace que
estas personas caigan en el consumo de
pornografía y se piense que la libertad
en la vivencia de la sexualidad es la
que nos vende el mercado en el mundo del
comercio de la sexualidad es así de
complejo sin embargo tenemos un camino
tenemos este camino que nos han abierto
estos niños los trovadores hitos y otros
grupos de niños que van trabajando
también en bolivia en relación a la
educación el poder dialogar el poder
reconceptualizar el poder mirar otras
opciones de relacionamiento dentro de
las familias de las escuelas y las
comunidades se constituyen en las
esperanzas y posibilidades para romper
cadenas de violencia doctora y ya para
el cierre una última pregunta sobre
educación lo decía nuestro corresponsal
en su reportaje que hay 23 mil denuncias
este año por agresiones en la familia y
las autoridades dicen que la causa está
en la forma en que son criados los
bolivianos pero nosotras somos las que
criamos a nuestros hijos y las
bolivianas son las que están criando
hombres y mujeres
estamos nosotros entonces perpetuando
una vivencia machista en la sociedad
como erradicamos esa discriminación que
nos rebota nosotros en la cara todo el
tiempo
bueno son dos temas que hay que
diferenciar uno la ineficiencia de los
sistemas judiciales no solamente en
bolivia sino en diferentes países lo que
nos brindan respuesta inmediata pronta a
la atención a la sanción y a la
restauración de derechos de las personas
pero por el otro lado está esta vivencia
machista que efectivamente hace a
hombres ya mujeres no solamente tiene
que ver con el accionar de estos hombres
que se han constituido como instrumentos
de ataque de consumo y de control sino
también con el accionar que nosotras
vamos reproduciendo sin percatarnos que
nos sigue manteniendo en este lugar de
objetos ya para la exhibición para la
reproducción y para la producción
un círculo que hay que romper lo podemos
hacer con restricciones profundas y es
importante decir a la sociedad y
especialmente a los varones no se trata
de una lucha contra los varones se trata
de una lucha contra un sistema machista
que responde a una estructura patriarcal
que nos está costando desmontar pero que
lo vamos a lograr y que nos está
costando la vida muchas gracias a
ustedes por estar con nosotros y a
nuestros televidentes recordarles nos
están matando y no sólo afecta a las
mujeres nos afecta a todos sigan con
nosotros en france 24
[Música]